you could make up a word that doesn't
currently exist to describe aaron donald
and what he does on a field what would
you have that word be
don't know well i don't know it's a word
that doesn't exist
it's more of an expression i have no
idea
it's unbelievable though but how about
that that's an answer for you huh
hey coach mcvay if you want some words
that don't exist you need to talk to our
guy chris sims he can naturally
more naturally than baker mayfield and
otto beckham jr will ever have chemistry
chris sims naturally comes up with words
that don't exist and then they are
forever recorded in the book of sims
isms that's sean mcveigh talking about
aaron donald two-time defensive player
of the year sure fire hall of famer
still one of the most disruptive forces
in the nfl even when you put three guys
on him all right here's what we did and
this is something we're going to do on a
regular basis we're going to go back
games from the prior weekend re-watch
them talk about them in depth shireen's
choice this week the cowboys and the
rams
i'm i'm stunned
the cowboys game although the cowboys
lost the cowboys lost if i'da had my
pick i wouldn't have gone and and stared
at the wound of the vikings getting
their butts kicked by the packers so we
go cowboys rams and we got some
structure to this and let's start with
this who was the best player on the
field based upon what you saw the second
time well i wish i wish i could see that
word
rephrase that word that that sean
mcveigh just used but anytime aaron
donald's on the field i think he's the
best player on the field almost always i
mean
non-quarterbacks he's the best player on
the field every single time you got to
double him you got to triple him he was
everywhere
just as he always is four tackles the
sack very disruptive
he's a man among boys and he continues
to be and i think when we start to talk
about defensive player of the year from
start to finish we talk about aaron
donald but jaylen ramsey for me was a
close second i i thought he played
fantastic especially in man coverage
they did play quite a bit of zone i
didn't really notice that when i
initially watched the game but
re-watching re-watching the game this
morning it looked like they played quite
a bit of zone against the cowboys and
maybe when you have three receivers and
then they had a tight end for a while
with blake jarwin in there you do that
and zeke elliott
but but when he was in main coverage
especially at the end of the game he was
fantastic so it was a close second for
jalen ramsey but aaron donald i mean
he's the best player any time he's on
the field
and i'd go with that same assessment and
the thing that separates jalen ramsey on
sunday night was the fact that he sold
the opi
that wiped the big gain off the board
that would have potentially forced
overtime or ultimately resulted in the
cowboys winning the game in regulation
with that body language as he you know
he's getting that shove and it's not a
full-blown flop it's just enough of a
lean back to draw the flag and it worked
and that was a genius move by jaylen
ramsey also got to give some love to
alden smith first game in five years
and
he he he needs to lose some weight i
mean frankly i do too but you know he's
he looks a little thicker than what
we're used to he's not as lean as he was
he's not as long as he was and even in
that blue jersey that should be more
slimming than the white jersey both he
and everson griffin looked a little a
little over their ideal weights to me
which tells me this as these guys get in
better shape that pass rush is going to
get better and i saw demarcus lawrence
getting doubled from time to time that
opens up opportunities for aldon smith
and for everson griffin and i i think
that as we see especially smith get into
game shape shireen he's going to be even
more destructive and disruptive than he
was his first game back in nearly five
years
ten tackles in a sack mike that's the
first time since 2012 a cowboys player
has accomplished that and that was
anthony spencer's has been a long time
so not having played in five years that
was fantastic performance and i think
bigger and better thing to come and we
may see him look a lot like he did his
first couple years in the league i mean
that was impressive having laid off that
long there was no rust whatsoever
yeah he had 42 sacks in his first 43
regular season games which is uncanny
and now he's one for one in his return
we love a good redemption story and the
sky's the limit possibly for aldon smith
all right who had a game they'd like to
forget shireen
well i think you point to greg zerline
you know i know it was a long field goal
but the 53-yarder he missed in the first
half he's made a ton of those he's made
58.9 of his 50 yarders in his career
counting the one that he missed the
other night and he just expects to make
those and he said he would love to have
that one back and of course at that
point it would have been a tie game and
it would have been a no-brainer there on
fourth down you kicked the field goal to
take the lead late in the game 23-20 but
they didn't have a tie game and they
chose not to kick the field goal at that
point he did make a 33 yarder but him
going against his former team with john
fossil the special teams coordinator who
had gone from the rams to the cowboys i
think it was really big for him and he
would have loved to have made that one
especially if it would have made that
big of a difference in the game
i tell you what i am going to go with uh
kellen moore the play caller for the
dallas cowboys he's calling the plays
right he's still calling the plays he's
running the offensive call in the plays
he he should want to blame that on
someone else for the final drive of the
game they got the ball back with more
than well over two minutes i think it
was like 228 when they get the ball back
and i know they have a long way to go
but they only need a field goal to force
overtime and the clock's just bleeding
like there's
it just was
lackadaisical and some of that's on dak
prescott too but they never could get it
going there was a lot of short passes
shireen that weren't thrown toward the
sidelines with the idea of stopping the
clock i think that they got lulled into
thinking we got plenty of time there's
228 left they only had one timeout
remaining but like all of a sudden
they're down to 40 seconds and that's
when they uncork the long throw to
michael gallup almost as kind of quasi
desperation because they had allowed so
much of that time they had
to trickle away and they only moved the
ball like 20 yards so um i i really
think if you're kell and moore you got
to go back and you got to assess what's
your plan because at the end of the
first half they moved the ball
effectively and efficiently and got a
touchdown to take the lead 14 to 13.
where was that with the game on the line
when all you need is a field goal i was
stunned when you watched that again you
know it's almost like when you have that
nightmare and you're trying to run away
from someone and it feels like you're
running in mud you're running in slow
motion you can't get away i just felt
like that's what their entire offense
was doing on that last drive
cowboys fans still are questioning why
mike mccarthy isn't calling the play
something that he wouldn't give up in
green bay he's allowing kellen moore to
do it he's in his second year of doing
it first game of his second year and to
me it was not a very good well-called
game and a lot of questions in that
especially you're right at that last
drive that they had but we're going to
get into some more of the the third down
and fourth down plays there when they
decided to to not kick the field goal
and go for it but there were some
questionable
questionable calls in that game by
calamore
the uh and let's let's stick with that
shireen um the the the play that that i
think was the most significant of the
game both from a call standpoint and
from an execution and design standpoint
the fourth and three with plenty of time
left in the game right my preference in
that spot take the field goal tie the
game assuming the field goal is good and
who knows with greg zarline maybe it
would have been good but it wasn't a
50-plus yarder it was a kick he should
have made
make it a tie game and move forward
instead the third down play and when you
go back and look at that i i i noticed
and i i noticed two things
the the the first of all
the the play as chris collinsworth
pointed out in real time the safety
weaving around traffic
and making the stop short of the sticks
was impressive but also to put the ball
in the hands of a rookie who i think
when you look at cd lamb's body language
after he makes the catch i don't think
he had any idea there was someone right
on top of him there was none of that
effort to stick the ball out to lunge
his body forward it looked like he was
trying to just think about where you
know is he going to go to the sideline
is he going to cut it up and the next
thing you know he's got someone on top
of him before he can get to the line to
gain
i am certain that they talked about this
and they had decided they're going to go
for it they faced a third and six but to
me that was an egregious play call there
to run the ball with ezekiel elliott and
i know they thought they were going to
catch the rams flat-footed on that by by
going to the run but i mean this is a
game where ezekiel had averaged 4.4
yards i carry again didn't have any runs
over 20 yards which we know he only had
four last year he didn't pick up the
first down so now you face a fourth and
three and you go to your rookie receiver
who i know we think is going to be
really good but he's in his first game
no preseason he doesn't run beyond the
sticks a rookie error right there and he
probably didn't know that jordan fuller
was right there but no effort to to make
the first down once that jordan fuller
was there and it was just a huge to me
it was more on the play caller and the
decision by dak prescott perhaps that
than it was by cd lamb not not getting
there to the sticks but yeah rookie
error and and all those things just
combined to now the rams have the ball
and you never get any closer that to tie
in the game or win in the game cowboys
fans wanted this coach to be aggressive
he was aggressive it's hard to argue
about him deciding to go for it on
fourth down but i would have liked for
them to do something different on that
third down play
and then they still had the chance to
tie the game and or when we talked about
the opi call that was sold aggressively
and successfully by rams cornerback
jaylen ramsey here's mike mccarthy coach
of the cowboys in the aftermath of the
game one day later talking about the
decision to wipe that big gain off the
board
i mean a michael gallop call i mean it's
just
made me sick when i watched the tv copy
um i thought michael ran an excellent
route you know he gets his hips
over top of the dbs and you know db
uh attempts to clamp his arm and
actually is clamped his arm and he pulls
his arm out makes makes a catch it's
definitely a call
you like seeing that happen and i know
everybody wants to talk about you know
the time of the game and you know in the
way the game was called to that point
but at the end of the day it was an
excellent route and throw
in completion by michael gallup and dak
i think it's funny he says everybody
wants to talk about the time of the game
he's the one that talked about the time
of the game he's the one that said this
is the time of the game where you don't
make that call and he's right he pivoted
on monday to the idea that at any time
of the game that call shouldn't be made
and you know hey shireen maybe
maybe i'm forgetting or not properly
understanding how this works but aren't
you supposed to not be criticizing the
officiating it's going to be interesting
to see whether or not mike mccarthy ends
up getting a letter from the league you
know the league's more concerned about
guys wearing their masks maybe he's
found an opportunity to criticize the
officials when the league's otherwise
got its hands full but this is the kind
of thing they don't want coaches to do
because he is dangerously close to the
line if not over the line by pointing
out that he doesn't believe that call
should have been made and pass
interference obviously in recent years
has become a source subject for the nfl
and mike i asked this in my post
yesterday if that's not jaylen ramsey if
it's not one of the best cornerbacks in
the nfl that
sells that play
does that flag get thrown and i watching
it again today i watched it
multiple times i did see two flags and
they did come out i would say really
quickly before jalen really really
starts selling it they were quick flags
and there were two flags there wasn't
just one flag but i still questioned
whether if if that wasn't jalen ramsey
on michael gallup if that if that flag
is thrown
real quickly on the way out give me a
guy who wasn't as good or as bad as you
first thought after further review of
the game
oh i would say dalton schultz that the
cowboys back up tied in and they're
going to be relying on him a lot and
they used a fairly high pick a high
third day pick on him and he's done
nothing in his careers in the last year
of his contract was not expected to do
much this year
and now blake jarwin's hurt and they're
going to be counting on him i thought he
was better than i thought he has been in
the last couple years
for me it was jared goff but not that he
was as good or as bad that as i
originally thought he i just i i i
emerged with no opinion i thought i'd
watch it again and think hey you know
what he was pretty good or oh you know
what he was pretty bad it was a mixed
bag for jared goff he had that great
throw on that third down conversion
uh to josh reynolds where he was covered
he was covered and any any any put the
ball in the only spot where it could
have been made to extend the drive but
then you know he's got that long looping
motion there was a ball that was tipped
i think by everson griffin at the line
of scrimmage and and there was a screen
pass and i don't know i'm anxious to see
whether they ask him about it this week
there was a screen pass they set up with
motion to the other side and robert
woods was open and goff like threw the
ball into the ground and came up and hit
the the offensive lineman right in the
ass
and i'm thinking man that was ugly but
then when you look there was a cowboys
player closing on that hard and i wonder
whether that was an abort a smart abort
by jared goff to see that that play was
red and it was going to get ugly i was
going to get blown up or maybe picked
off but it was an ugly looking throw at
the moment but it may have been a smart
move by goff so i don't know he was
neither and i didn't expect to watch
that game back and emerge thinking jared
goff was neither good nor bad
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports